un contact direct et pas seulement par
courrier 18 entreprises et deux
organismes de formation ont participé à
ce job dating coup de pouce pour
l'emploi le deuxième organisé à la
verrière en début d'opération tous les
recruteurs se présente devant l'ensemble
des candidats déjà ça leur permet de
voir qu'ils vont avoir en face d'eux et
ensuite c'est une rencontre ben qui
fonctionne ou non mais on en dit plus
sur soi quand on rencontre une personne
qu'avec un simple cv auxiliaire de vie
agents de recouvrement techniciens de
maintenance
les postes proposés sont pour des débuts
de carrière sans qualification à bac + 2
j'aime bien voir autre chose lorsque
quelqu un qui moi personnellement j'aime
bien essayer d'autres choses dans la vie
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant de démarcher dans ce genre
de concept parce que déjà les ce qui en
fin les employeurs ils viennent
directement nous voir ils nous proposent
ils nous font un listing sur leurs
entreprises 92 jeunes de 18 à 35 ans se
sont présentées dans les yvelines les
moins de 49 ans était près de 50000 au
chômage au deuxième trimestre 2010 8